cleaning up the debris from a russian
strike people are happy to be alive and
only dealing with blown out windows
thursday's explosions in kiev were loud
close and unexpected
the first one struck on that side it was
really loud
i thought it fell somewhere near my
office after about 10 seconds the second
one hit here
i shut myself from the toilet i closed
the door and i thought there would be
another one but thank god there were no
more
a reminder the war could grow closer to
home at any time the constant threat
that's too much to bear
they've killed so many people it's
really difficult
our brothers thanks to them for our
freedom they won't leave anything
standing i can't take it anymore
russia's defense ministry called it a
high precision strike on a space rocket
facility in the heart of the capital it
was the first time the city was hit in
several weeks and happened less than an
hour after un secretary general antonio
guterres wrapped up a news conference
with the ukrainian president
proof says zielinski that nothing can be
negotiated with russia without security
guarantees
this says a lot about russia's true
attitude towards global institutions
about attempts of russian authorities to
humiliate un and everything that the
organization represents therefore it
requires corresponding powerful reaction
rescue workers recovered one body from
rubble beneath the residential tower
block as cleanup operations began on
friday the u.s funded radio liberty says
a producer was killed by the strike
ten people were treated for injuries the
mayor says safety cannot be guaranteed
it's still a dangerous place and
this gives they are still the target of
russians
the attack shattered a relative calm
which had drawn many residents back to
the city no one knows what missiles
bombs or other messages could be sent by
russian forces regardless of who's in
town andrew chappelle al jazeera